♪♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
JOHN FETTERMAN IS A TRUST FUND
KID, TOOK MONEY FROM HIS PARENTS
DEEP INTO MIDDLE AGE, WHEN HE
DECIDED WHAT TO DO WITH THE REST
OF HIS LIFE, BE THE U.S. SENATOR
FROM PENNSYLVANIA.
THE PROBLEM IS FATE INTERVENED,
AND HE CAN NO LONGER SPEAK.
WE FEEL BAD ABOUT THAT.
EVERYONE DOES.
BECAUSE OF THAT STROKE, HE NEEDS
ELECTRONIC ASSISTANCE IN ORDER
TO COMMUNICATE WITH OTHER
PEOPLE.
HE CAN'T TALK ON HIS OWN.
IT'S NOT A RIGHT WING CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
IT'S NOT Q ANON.
HE USES A SOFTWARE PROGRAM TO
UNDERSTAND THOSE AROUND HIM AND
TO TALK.
THIS SOFTWARE IS NOT A HEARING
AID.
FETTERMAN DOESN'T NEED A HEARING
HE'S NOT DEAF.
HE'S NOT HEARING IMPAIRED.
INSTEAD THIS PROGRAM TAKES WORDS
AND REARRANGES THEM INTO
LANGUAGE THAT JOHN FETTERMAN CAN
UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE HIS BRAIN
CAN NO LONGER DO THAT FOR HIM.
THAT'S SAD FOR TRANSHUMANNISTS,
THOUGH, IT'S THRILLING.
THIS IS AN AMAZING MOMENT.
THIS IS NEIL ARMSTRONG ON THE
MOON.
HERE YOU HAVE ONE OF THE MOST
FAMOUS POLITICIANS IN THE
COUNTRY MERGING WITH A COMPUTER.
THIS IS THE FUTURE THEY IMAGINE.
THEY'RE THRILLED FOR IT.
FOR EVERYONE ELSE, FOR THE
VOTERS OF PENNSYLVANIA, IT
RAISES QUESTIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHERE DOES THE
SOFTWARE END AND JOHN
FETTERMAN'S CONSCIOUSNESS BEGIN?
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE CAN'T KNOW.
BUT IT'S OBVIOUS THAT
PENNSYLVANIA COULD VERY WELL BE
SENDING A COMPUTER PROGRAM TO
THE U.S. SENATE, WHERE
INEVITABLY IT WILL BE HACKED.
YESTERDAY MSNBC SAT DOWN WITH
JOHN FETTERMAN AND HIS THINKING
MACHINE TO ASSESS WHERE THE MAN
ENDS AND THE MACHINE BEGINS.
THE INITIAL IMPRESSIONS WERE NOT
AT ALL ENCOURAGING.
>> WE HAD A MONITOR SET UP SO
THAT HE COULD READ MY QUESTIONS,
BECAUSE HE STILL HAS LINGERING
AUDITORY PROCESSING ISSUES AS A
RESULT OF THE STROKE, WHICH
MEANS HE HAS A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HE'S HEARING.
ONCE HE READS THE QUESTION, HE'S
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU'LL HEAR HE ALSO STILL SOME
PROBLEMS, SOME CHALLENGES, WITH
SPEECH.
I WILL SAY, KATIE, JUST IN THE
SMALL TALK PRIOR TO THE
INTERVIEW BEFORE THE CLOSE
CAPTIONING WAS UP AND RUNNING,
IT DID SEEM THAT HE HAD A HARD
TIME UNDERSTANDING OUR
CONVERSATIONS.
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD FOR HER
FOR ADMITTING THAT.
THAT'S A RIVAL CHANNEL.
THAT'S MSNBC.
SHE SHOULD TELL VIEWERS THAT,
AND SHE DID.
SHE SAID BEFORE THE MACHINE WAS
TURNED ON, JOHN FETTERMAN
COULDN'T UNDERSTAND HUMAN
LANGUAGE, NOT EVEN SMALL TALK.
ONCE THE MACHINE WAS PLUGGED,
SHE SOUNDED NEARLY HUMAN.
DON'T WORRY.
EVERYTHING WILL BE FINE IN THE
SENATE AS LONG AS THERE'S NOT A
POWER OUTAGE.
NOT LIKE THE ELECTRICITY GOES
DOWN IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE RENEWABLES TO KEEP JOHN
FETTERMAN VOTING FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS.
BUILD MORE WIND FARMS.
THAT'S THE PLAN.
SHE DID ASK A FOLLOW-UP, HOW DO
WE KNOW YOUR MACHINE ISN'T GOING
TO BREAK, JOHN FETTERMAN?
CAN WE SEE A DOCTOR'S REPORT ON
THIS?
HERE'S YOU HOW THAT EXCHANGE
WENT.
>> CAN YOU DO THIS JOB ON DAY
ONE?
>> OF COURSE.
>> SO YOU'RE SAY YOU'RE ON THE
ROAD TO FULL RECOVERY.
BUT RIGHT NOW VOTERS REALLY HAVE
TO TAKE YOUR WORD FOR IT.
WE'VE ASKED FOR YOUR MEDICAL
RECORDS.
WE'VE ASKED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH SOMEONE FROM
YOUR MEDICAL TEAM TO INTERVIEW
YOUR PHYSICIAN.
YOU'VE DECLINED THOSE REQUESTS.
WHY?
>> I FEEL WE HAVE BEEN VERY
TRANSPARENT IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS, WHEN OUR DOCTOR
HAS ALREADY GIVEN A LETTER
SAYING I'M ABLE TO SERVE, AND TO
BE RUNNING.
>> I MEAN, RESPECTFULLY THAT
LETTER FROM YOUR PHYSICIAN, THAT
WAS SIX MONTHS AGO.
DON'T VOTERS DESERVE TO KNOW
YOUR STATUS NOW?
>> BEING IN FRONT OF THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, HAVING
INTERVIEWS AND GETTING AROUND
ALL ACROSS PENNSYLVANIA, THAT
GIVES EVERYBODY AND THE VOTERS,
THEY CAN DECIDE IF THAT'S THE
ISSUE.
>> Tucker: HE'S READING THAT OFF
A SCREEN.
BY THE WAY, WE'RE TAKING HIM AT
HIS WORD THAT THERE'S NOT A
STAFFER BACKSTAGE TYPING OUT THE
ANSWERS BECAUSE HE CAN'T
FORMULATE THAT.
YOU CAN FEEL SYMPATHETIC, THAT'S
SAD TO WATCH, BUT HE WANTS TO
RUN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, A
BODY OF 100, THE MOST POWERFUL
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN THE WORLD,
AND HE WANTS TO BE A MEMBER OF
IT.
OVER AT CBS, ED O'KEEFE ASKED
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION, WILL
PENNSYLVANIANS BE COMFORTABLE
WITH SOMEONE REPRESENTING THEM
WHO HAD TO CONDUCT A TV
INTERVIEW THIS WAY.
THAT'S A MILD WAY OF PUTTING IT,
BUT IT'S A FAIR OBSERVATION.
THE GUY IS READING OFF HIS
ANSWERS OFF THE SCREEN WITH THE
REPORTER THREE FEET AWAY.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
IMPAIRMENT.
AND AGAIN, THIS IS A VERY
SERIOUS JOB.
BUT OTHERS IN THE MEDIA SCOFFED
AT THE IDEA THAT WAS A PROBLEM
AT ALL.
IN FACT, FAR FROM BEING A
PROBLEM, IT WAS AN ASSET,
BECAUSE IF THE EQUITY AGENDA
MEANS ANYTHING, IT MEANS THAT
INCOMPETENT PEOPLE OUGHT TO BE
IN CHARGE.
THAT'S EQUITY.
AS ONE COUNCILWOMAN PUT IT,
QUESTIONS ABOUT HIM, IT'S
ENABLIST.
WE NEED MORE DIVERSITY IN
ELECTED OFFICE, INCLUDING PEOPLE
WITH SPEECH IMPEDIMENTS.
WE DESPERATELY NEED THAT.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
ACTUALLY WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
A SPEECH IMPEDIMENT.
SHE'S TELLING US HE HAS A
STUTTER.
REMEMBER WHEN THEY TOLD US JOE
BIDEN'S SPEECH, HE HAD JUST A
STUTTER?
IT DIDN'T PREVENT HIM FROM
UNDERSTANDING PEOPLE'S SPEECH.
"THE NEW YORKER" ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION WITH A QUESTION.
WOULD THEY TREAT A DEAF PERSON
LIKE THIS FOR NEEDING
ASSISTANCE?
OH, SO IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT JOHN FETTERMAN, YOU HATE
THE DEAF.
YOU'RE A HEARINGIST, BIGOT.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE DOWN YOUR
BANK ACCOUNT AT JPMORGAN.
ENABLIST.
AGAIN, IT'S NOT REALLY RELEVANT
TO THE SENATE RACE IN
PENNSYLVANIA, BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN
JOHN FETTERMAN DOESN'T HAVE
HEARING PROBLEMS.
HE'S NOT DEAF.
THIS ISN'T DEAFNESS.
THIS IS BRAIN DAMAGE.
SO "THE INDEPENDENCE" TRIED TO
TIE UP LOOSE ENDS AND USED AN
ANALOGY.
HOW IS THIS DIFFERENT FROM TAMMY
DUCKWORTH OR MADISON CAWTHORNE
NEEDING A WHEELCHAIR?
OH, SO THIS IS EXACTLY THE SAME
AS BEING WOUNDED IN DEFENSE OF
YOUR OWN COUNTRY.
IT'S A WAR INJURY.
HA-HA-HA!
AND THEN JOHN FETTERMAN'S WIFE,
WHO CAME INTO THIS COUNTRY AS AN
ILLEGAL ALIEN, BY THE WAY,
WONDERED THE SAME THING.
AND WE'RE QUOTING, TRULY
APPALLING.
HAVE THESE JOURNALISTS NEVER
HEARD OF THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT?
REALLY CURIOUS TO LEARN HOW THEY
FEEL ABOUT WHEELCHAIRS AND
GLASSES, END QUOTE.
REALLY?
SO YOUR QUESTIONS ABOUT JOHN
FETTERMAN'S MENTAL HEALTH, THE
ACUTE OF HIS BRAIN, HIS ABILITY
TO TALK AND LISTEN AND REASON,
USE HIS HIGHER FACULTIES, THOSE
QUESTIONS ARE BANNED BY THE
AMERICAN WITH DISABILITIES ACT,
BECAUSE HE'S NOT ONLY AN
INCOMPETENT GUY TRYING TO TAKE
OVER THE COUNTRY.
NO, HE'S DISABLED.
QUOTE, IS IT THE POSITION OF NBC
NEWS THAT A SENATOR WITH GLASSES
CANNOT BE TRUSTED IN OFFICE
BECAUSE THEY USE ASSISTIVE
TECHNOLOGY TO ASSIST THEIR
DISABILITY?
HA-HA-HA!
SO UNBELIEVABLE.
NOT ONLY CAN YOU ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE GUY, WHETHER HE CAN
REPRESENT YOU IN THE UNITED
STATES SENATE, HE'S FINE.
AND, BY THE WAY, THE REASON HE'S
NOT FINE, IS THE REASON TO VOTE
FOR HIM.
THEY'RE HITTING YOU FROM BOTH
SIDES.
HA-HA-HA.
IF YOU KNOW HE'S PROFOUNDLY
DISABLED, YOU'RE A BIGOT.
WHEW!
THEY GOT YOU COMING AND GOING.
HAVE YOU HEARD THIS BEFORE?
DOES IT SOUND KIND OF FAMILIAR,
WHERE THEY TAKE SOMETHING WITH
AN OBVIOUS IMPAIRMENT AND USE
HIM TO ACCRUE MORE POWER FOR
THEMSELVES?
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT THE
DISABLED PERSON.
IT'S ABOUT THEM.
AND THEN IF YOU ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT, SHUT UP, BIGOT!
DOES THE TERM GRETA THUNBURG
COME TO MIND, THE GIRL WHO'S
ALWAYS LECTURING YOU ABOUT
GLOBAL WARMING?
SHE NEEDED HELP AND CONCERN FROM
ADULTS.
AT THE AGE OF 11, SHE LOST
22 POUNDS, BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
HER PARENTS, SHE WAS SO
DEPRESSED ABOUT GLOBAL WARMING
SHE COULDN'T EAT.
THEN SHE WAS DIAGNOSED A WHOLE
SUITE OF SERIOUS PROBLEMS, OCD,
MUTISM, AND ASPERGER'S.
THE PEOPLE AROUND HER DIDN'T SEE
IT AS SAD AT ALL.
THEY SAW IT AS AN ADVANTAGE FOR
THEM, BECAUSE SHE COULD BE USED
TO ACCRUE MORE POWER TO THEM.
AND YOU WEREN'T ALLOWED TO SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT IT, BECAUSE SHE
WAS DISABLED, WHICH, BY THE WAY,
YOU WEREN'T ALLOWED TO NOTICE.
>> YOU WILL COME TO US YOUNG
PEOPLE FOR HOPE.
HOW DARE YOU.
YOU HAVE STOLEN MY DREAMS AND MY
CHILDHOOD WITH YOUR EMPTY WORDS.
WE ARE IN THE BEGINNING OF A
MASS EXTINCTION, AND ALL YOU CAN
TALK ABOUT IS FAIRY TALES OF
ETERNAL ECONOMIC GROWTH.
HOW DARE YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU LOOK AT THAT, AND
ON ONE LEVEL YOU THINK WHY IS
THIS PERSON LECTURING ME,
SOMEONE WHO'S HAD NEVER HAD A
JOB BEFORE, IN CHARGE OF OUR
ENERGY POLICY?
THAT'S CRAZY.
THEN THE OTHER LEVEL, THE MORE
DEEP LEVEL, THE MORE IMPORTANT
LEVEL, YOU REALIZE WHAT A
TRAGEDY YOU JUST SAW.
HERE'S SOMEONE WHO IS PROFOUNDLY
TROUBLED, WHO NEEDS REAL HELP
AND CARE AND EMPATHY AND LOVE
FROM THE ADULTS IN HER LIFE, BUT
SHE'S NOT GETTING ANY OF THAT.
INSTEAD SHE'S BEING CARTED OUT
LIKE A SIDESHOW FREAK FOR THE
PROFIT OF OTHERS.
THEY'RE USING THAT CHILD IN
EXACTLY THE WAY THEY'RE USING
JOE BIDEN AND JOHN FETTERMAN --
AND, BY THE WAY, KAMALA HARRIS,
THE DIMMEST PERSON TO EVER WORK
IN AMERICAN POLITICS -- NONE OF
THEM HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT'S GOING
ON, BEING USED BY PEOPLE FOR THE
BENEFIT.
THOSE PEOPLE.
BUT YOU CAN'T SAY ANYTHING,
BECAUSE YOU WOULD BE AGAINST
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES, AND
THE ADA PROHIBITS YOU FROM
DOING, RIGHT?
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO ACCOMMODATE
GRETA'S DISABILITY, PRETEND HER
WORDS ARE PROFOUND.
JUST LIKE THE FAKE POET AT
BIDEN'S ADMINISTRATION.
OH, SHE WAS SO GREAT.
WE DARE YOU TO SAY SHE WASN'T.
HA-HA-HA!
SHE WAS RIDICULOUS.
IN GRETA'S CASE, OF COURSE THE
MEDIA LOVED IT, BECAUSE THEY
COULD USE HER TOO.
SHE COULD DIE AND THEY WOULDN'T
CARE.
THEY'D FIND SOMEONE ELSE TO USE
AS A MARIONETTE FOR THEIR OWN
POLITICAL AMBITIONS.
WATCH THEM.
>> PERHAPS THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
AND IMPASSIONED REMARKS HAVE
COME NOT FROM A PRIME MINISTER
OR PRESIDENT BUT A 16-YEAR-OLD.
>> A TEENAGER ON STRIKE FOR THE
PLANET.
>> OUR HOUSE IS ON FIRE.
>> "TIMES" PERSON OF THE YEAR.
>> CHANGE IS COMING, WHETHER YOU
LIKE IT OR NOT.
>> SHE'S LEADING A GENERATION OF
CLIMATE KIDS.
>> THAT'S A HORSE TO BE RECKONED
WITH.
>> THE SWEDISH GIRL WHO INSPIRED
SO MUCH.
SHE SAID SHE WAS IN A DEEP
DEPRESSION WHEN SHE UNDERSTOOD
THE WARNINGS OF SCIENCE, BUT
TURNED THE DEPRESSION INTO
ACTION.
YOU CAN SEE THE RESULT HERE
TODAY.
>> GRETA'S PASSION DOES REFLECT
WHAT REALLY IS HAPPENING.
WE'RE STILL ARGUING WHETHER OR
NOT IT EXISTS?
>> Tucker: SHE TURNED THAT
DEPRESSION INTO ACTION.
WELL, NO, SHE DIDN'T, ACTUALLY.
SHE'S LIVING IN HELL, LIKE MOST
EMOTIONALLY UNBALANCED CHILDREN.
SHE'S SUFFERING, BUT YOU DON'T
CARE BECAUSE YOU CAN USE HER.
YOU DID NOTHING TO SUPPORT HER,
TO LOVE HER, TO CURE HER SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS.
NO.
YOU USED HER TO TAKE MORE POWER.
IF ANYONE SAYS ANYTHING ABOUT
IT, IF YOU THINK CHILDREN
SHOULDN'T GO ON TELEVISION TO
TALK ABOUT CLIMATE POLICY AND
ENERGY, THEN YOU'RE A BIGOT.
YOU HATE CHILDREN.
YOU ATE GRETA THUNBERG.
BY THE WAY, AS YOU SIT AND WATCH
THE RESULTS OF THE LUNATIC
POLICY SHE'S ESPOUSING WITHOUT
EVEN UNDERSTANDING EUROPE'S
ENERGY GRID COLLAPSING THEN
YOU'RE A BAD PERSON.
AS FOX REPORTED, ATTACKS EXPOSE
WHAT SHE MUST FACE.
NO.
THEY USED HER SUFFERING TO HER
OWN BENEFIT.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" COMPLAINED
AUTISTIC YOUNG PEOPLE RESERVE
ATTENTION AND RESPECT.
REALLY?
WHOSE PAWN IS SHE?
YOURS.
THERE WAS A STUDY OF ANALYSIS OF
AGEISM, ENABLISM, AND YOUTUBE
VIDEOS ABOUT CLIMATE ACTIVIST
GRETA THUNBERG.
OH.
SO AGAIN YOU NEED TO LISTEN TO
HER BECAUSE SHE'S NOT WELL, BUT
IF YOU NOTE SHE'S NOT WELL
YOU'RE A BIGOT.
IT'S THE SAME, EXACTLY THE SAME
DYNAMIC YOU'RE WATCHING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
JOE BIDEN, WHO IS NOT WELL AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
JOE BIDEN MOURNED THE DEFT OF
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE WALORSKI
PUBLICLY, AND THEN ASKED,
TOTALLY BEFUDDLED, WHY ISN'T SHE
HERE AT THE EVENT.
IF YOU NOTICED THAT HAPPENED,
YOU'RE THE AGEIST.
>> COME ON.
YOU CAN'T GO AFTER HIM FOR NOT
GIVING AID TO FLORIDA, NOT
TACKLING THE INFRASTRUCTURE,
HE'S GIVING AID TO UKRAINE.
SO YOU CAN'T GO AFTER HIM FOR
THAT, BUT YOU CAN GO AOF HIM FOR
FORGETTING THAT SOMEONE HAS
PASSED.
SHE PASSED LAST MONTH, NOT LIKE
100 YEARS AGO.
>> I THINK WHAT IT REALLY SHOWS
IS THAT THIS COUNTRY IS SO
AGEIST.
THIS COUNTRY HAS A PROBLEM WITH
AGE.
I THINK THEY NEED TO STOP
WEAPONIZING HIS AGE.
I HATE THAT ABOUT THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: HA-HA-HA.
THIS COUNTRY IS A PROBLEM WITH
AGE.
SO IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE FACT
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF, THE GUY
THAT COMMANDS OUR NUCLEAR
ARSENAL IS DERANGED BECAUSE OF
AGE, WHICH HE IS, THEN YOU'RE
THE BIGOT.
BUT UNDERNEATH ALL OF THIS IS
THIS SINGLE MOST CYNICAL
POLITICAL MOVE IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
THAT IS ELEVATING JOE BIDEN
PRECISELY BECAUSE HE IS FADING
AWAY.
BECAUSE HE IS DEMEND.
THAT'S WHY THEY CHOSE HIM.
THEY HAD AN OPTION ACTUALLY.
HIS NAME WAS BERNIE SANDERS.
WE'RE HARDLY ENDORSING BERNIE
SANDERS' PROGRAM, BUT BERNIE
SANDERS CAN THINK CLEARLY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HATED WHAT
HE HAD TO SAY.
SO THEY PICKED A GUY, WHO HAD